there's an opening at the White House
President Trump faces a new round of
staff turmoil after as long as serving
aid revealed she will leave her job in
the next few weeks the departure of
White House communications director hope
Hicks was announced one day after she
testified to a House committee
investigating Russian election meddling
Pope Hicks joins a list of more than 20
officials to part ways with the Trump
administration she started working for
the president before he ran for office
Hicks is also close to his daughter
Ivanka and son-in-law Jared Kushner
sources tell CBS News her exit is seen
as a win for the president's chief of
staff John Kelly Face the Nation
moderator Margaret Brennan is at the
White House Margaret good morning good
morning well this was tough news for
hope Hicks to break to the staff
yesterday after being right by Donald
Trump's side for three years now but the
White House said she had been planning
to depart for months and that she wants
to take a job outside of government
get up here hope hope it's the legendary
hope it hope Hicks took an unlikely path
to power starting off as a fashion model
before joining the Trump family
businesses and now maintains a direct
line to the President of the United
States no comment at all
on Tuesday she spent nine hours
testifying before the House Intelligence
Committee which is investigating Russian
interference in the 2016 election during
her testimony she said that she never
lied about Russia but her role did
require her to tell white lies reporting
of the remark miffed the president but
did not play a role in her exit
congressional investigators and Special
Counsel Robert Muller are probing
Hicks's role in helping to draft a
misleading statement on behalf of Donald
Trump jr. regarding a June 2016 meeting
at Trump Tower between campaign
officials and Russian nationals
earlier this month news of her
relationship with former White House
staff Secretary Rob Porter also became
public porter resigned after it was
disclosed that his FBI background check
had revealed domestic abuse allegations
Hicks had helped craft the White House's
defense of him when the news broke the
combination of all of that tension and
chief of staff John Kelly's tightening
of the reins took a toll on him
who has stuck by the president's side
during some of the rockiest spots on the
campaign trail and since inauguration I
said what do you know about politics she
said absolutely nothing she knew nothing
and she was there the first day and she
was fantastic
their relationship is close she was one
of the first people the president
informed of his intent to run for office
in a statement yesterday the president
said quote I will miss having her by my
side and I am sure that we will work
together again in the future now the
current deputy head of communications is
a leading candidate to replace hope
Hicks but no date for her own departure
or selection of her replacement has
officially been made John that's right
and no one will have the kind of close
relationship with President Trump that
hope had Margaret this is being talked
about as a win for the chief of staff
who's been trying to bring more order to
the White House why is that the case
well according to my colleague major
Garrett's reporting that win idea has to
do with the fact that as you say hope
Hicks is so close to daughter Ivanka
Trump and son-in-law Jared Kushner and
because of that familial relationship it
has been hard for them to really fall in
line with that overall restructuring
that chief of staff John Kelly has put
in place are they staff members are they
family members the line is by definition
blurred here but also hope Hicks put
together that statement in the wake of
Rob quarters the scandal about his
departure and it put chief of staff John
Kelly in a place of looking like he was
defending him something he then later
had to moderate given that the
allegations do appear to be credible and
just quickly there been a lot of
departures from the White House this is
another one you're right there have been
about two dozen some of this is just
simply burnout at the end of first year
of an administration that's typical some
of it has to do with other reasons but
in those cases like Rob Porter those
scandals those self-inflicted issues
have become frankly a distraction for
the president's agenda
Margaret thanks